do fun like actually douches it's fun so
I'm actually taking more time in the
evenings to spend with you than I ever
would during the week because I'm like
this is gonna be the best time ever this
is gonna be the most fun I'm gonna look
back and be like yeah the quarantine
when's it coming back because you know
to me and like really have fun with it
like find a way to make it exceptional
your morning routine makes the
difference between going through a day
of misery and fear and apathy or be
productive and serving and using this
time to lift your life I mean in in the
5 a.m. Club there's the the 20-20-20
formula it explains exactly what to do
between 5:00 and 6:00 to battle proof
your mindset to purify your hearts to
strengthen your health set and to
elevate your soul set what I call the
four interior empires in the book but
for now I'll just simply say the way you
begin your day right now is going to
dramatically affect the way your day
unfolds so start it with some exercise
so you release BDNF dopamine which makes
you feel better
serotonin which makes you feel better
and you know reduces the cortisol the
fear hormone start your day with
exercise which will release
norepinephrine which will allow greater
focus in your mind so will BDNF now if
you're at home you can say oh I can't
get to the gym jumping jacks
skipping running on the spot push-ups
burpees
you can do it in any room even if you're
in one room that will release BDNF which
accelerates the brain and focus so
meditation exercise 3
journaling journaling will allow you to
process through do it early in the
morning because like that's the morning
routine when you journal you can release
your fear you can release the emotions
of loneliness or and put them on a page
which allows you to feel much more free
so you can focus and and I think those
are three specific tactics that allow
you to start your your day better final
thing I'd say is prayer prayer works
very well for me even 3 or 4 minutes to
lock you into your highest largest self
is powerful I just don't want to put the
drink down
they say that success happens when you
see the world through the bottom of a
glass there we go on to the main event
[Music]
alright so this week's main event this
cheap meal so this cheat meal if you
guys could see it this is four inch
thick french toast and it is a personal
recipe of mine it's a specialty that I
love it is my go-to every single week
now this isn't only what I have I have
this and I'm sharing this with you guys
but I also have some I also I have some
all sorts of users and cookies some
chocolate chip cookies I also have the
chocolate chip cookies but here's the
thing with the chocolate chips I don't
know you guys feel but I gotta have I
gotta have milk chocolate milk chocolate
I'm not a big semi-sweet fan because
it's a little it's there's a little
bitterness kwatak quality to it so I
gotta have the milk chocolate how so did
big peanut butter chocolate chip cookies
too as well and I do a ton of pasta
throughout the day but it's today what's
up Canada good to see you
usually Sunday's my cheat day and the
only time the only reason why I know
it's Sunday because I've lost complete
track of days I'm sure you guys have
this because it's cheap day alright so
here we go the main event brioche french
toast if you guys can get your hands on
some brioche bread
I cut it four inches thick because I am
hungry
and and I just I love a big thick ass
french toast so basically when you put
these together this is the loaf and then
I cut off the ends
of it and then I cut off the ends of it
here and then the ends what I usually do
is is I usually make a grilled cheese
sandwich because the Greed's and the two
mills it just keeps going throughout the
day throughout the day I could consume
anywhere between eight to ten thousand
calories and that is a legitimate guess
you're probably like really yes this is
the this is the evidence a great cheat
meal when things are different you know
it's is where a lot of humor kind of
comes out about difficulties or
challenges in in life how for you kind
of is that happening kind of in the
moment you find yourself is that part of
your coping mechanism is it part of the
way that you relate to the people around
you are you finding it as a source of my
creative inspiration um you know look
you can't sit me down for too long and
not expect me to come out of it better
somehow sitting me down for this long
you know you give me times to write you
give me time to think you're giving me
time to create on another level so when
it comes to my funny you know I got
20-plus years in this business now so my
funny is is broken down on so many
different levels now so it's not just
about me being funny it's about finding
funny that I can provide globally you
know what are the high P that I can
create right now you know what are the
things that I can create for this
digital space the streaming service it's
uh it's just it's ignited a real spark
in me to say I should come out of this
when it's over with five pieces of
material that can be strong and you know
evergreen in the world today so what are
those things so literally every day is a
writing day I wake up I check in go
the office my office I'm talking about
in my house and I yes it not just I just
chat and brainstorm you know something
to come out of it all of us not gonna be
going most of it but it's about finding
it's about finding that one thing that
may be good you know hopefully I'm
laying on something this is the time you
are locked up in your homes in your
rooms make use of this time to do
meditation
do not miss meditation every day at
least two times or thrice twice or
thrice you sit and meditate number one
second this is the time you can acquire
more knowledge third this is the time
you can acquire more skills you know you
can learn more languages you want to
learn language you can do yoga you can
do many things that you would do it in
recreational time you would use it in
your vacation nobody asked what do I do
in my vacation you find something to do
you go out now this time instead of
going out for vacation you sit and you
read books there's so much knowledge
watch as you know and the television so
many you know knowledge wisdom is
available and listen to music learn
music you can do a million thing you
know no need no point in sitting and
deep breath and reading the same old
news again and again and getting more
worked up and you can chat with people
there are so many people who are not
happy you are upset you can uplift them
their mood by talking you know use
social media this is the time to use
social media more and why don't you just
slow down calm down
cool down for few days you have that
ability don't forget that
you have the ability to just let go and
relax and do that more now more than any
other time it's essential you get your
your daily rituals in okay things are
going to get very unpredictable
for moments so right now you got to get
the things that you can control under
your control I assure you this situation
with the virus and what's going to
happen more importantly with the economy
is going to create stress on the systems
on families on finances I've been saying
for I don't know maybe nine ten months
now that we're already in the
contraction that will be proven out now
I'm not trying to be right I'm just
trying to inform you here to be
successful you don't need to be right or
wrong you need to be successful for you
and your family so what do you do what
am i doing right now discipline
discipline discipline get your rituals
in daily rituals when am i waking up
what's the first thing I do once I wake
up in my case I right my goal is down
third thing I do is I go to the gym and
get my workout in impossible
I miss this some days okay I can't
always get it done for whatever reason
and then I'm gonna have a target list of
things I want to accomplish during the
day who do I need to see who do I need
to call who do I need to followup on
this is going to become more and more
important if you've been struggling in
business it's gonna get tougher if it's
been easy for you it's gonna get tougher
if it's been great for you it's gonna
get tougher trust me it's going to get
tougher we've been 12 years into a
massive expansion the wealthy have
gotten wealthier the people that didn't
change didn't change the
finances didn't change while other
people got super-rich and that will
continue on the wealthy will get
wealthier both start making moves
they'll expand while others contract so
don't get scared now daily rituals set
it up what are you going to do on your
follow up your follow up customers
building contact list building your your
profile of people that you can talk to
work with have relationships with you're
gonna have to spend more energy and
resources now to stay in touch with that
base of people that you want to stay in
touch with okay one building
relationship if you're on your own
living alone and you have to self
isolate that is very hard for human
beings because we need people and our
immunity does better when we have
interactions but you can still connect
to people use the phone use the internet
talk to people do everything you can to
keep that connection going look out for
your neighbors especially elderly people
who are alone go out and do some
shopping walk their dog speak to Nover
the fence keeping that 6-foot barrier
there's so much we can do when we do
something we feel okay I'm doing
something I'm being proactive not
inactive so look for what's good about
it I know you think what's good about it
well you've got some time for you you
know some time to do the things that
matter look for what's good and remind
yourself this will pass in a world of
uncertainty I can give myself certainty
and if everything is changing and it's
out of my control
what can I control you can control your
thoughts your thoughts control your
feelings your feelings control your
actions and your actions control your
events in this time and uncertainty the
one thing you can always control are
your thoughts and if you can make your
thoughts positive it will change your
entire life if you want more advice
wisdom guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check
video right there next to me I hope you
find it valuable continue to believe and
I'll see you there when we have all
these terrible situations going on